le projet à mon humble avis dans le
batman doit être au moment où le
président marie jeanne fait cette
intervention les élus de l'assemblée ne
se sont pas encore exprimés et c'est
comme s'il sentait venir la fronde
autour du pad ma le futur plan
d'aménagement et de développement
durable de la martinique où est le débat
où est ce que j'ai dit que tout ce plan
d'aménagement présenté dans le détail
par louis boutrin devrait permettre aux
nouveaux développements pour la
martinique dans le domaine de l'économie
la santé ou encore les infrastructures
routières
nous avons un certain nombre d'outils
aujourd'hui le schéma territorial des
infrastructures routières le schéma de
la mobilité des déplacements tous ces
schémas vont qui intègre et le pad mac
est la matrice qui va pouvoir absorber
et mettre de la cohérence entre tous ces
schémas
sauf que de l'avis des conseillers de la
majorité louis douteraient a présenté un
dossier très avancé et qui ne laisse pas
de place à la réflexion des élus de
l'assemblée
certains conseillers exécutifs ne
communiquerait pas avec les présidents
de commissions de l'assemblée
même le président claude lise s'en est
ému
il ya un moment faut que ça cesse
l'assemblée et la désaffection des
palabres simplement qu'on lui dise
publiquement
voilà c'est pas un membre de l'assemblée
la présidente de l'adie aussi pas même
de l'assemblée n'a été consulté ni
lui-même non plus vous sur le sujet nous
sommes à plus de 82 81 fonctionnement
j'ai mon côté l'exécutif en charge des
mêmes domaines que moi bon je peux le
dire maintenant public je les ai
quasiment jamais vu que je peux dire
j'ai pas la langue de bois je dis les
choses
effectivement on sent un certain malaise
mais les élus de l'assemblée doivent
effectivement cv ce tir dans les
ateliers s'investir dans l'est la
commission d'élaboration du padma
l'opposition explique pour sa part que
ce document qui doit entre autres choses
en place et le sahara où les plu plans
locaux d'urbanisme ne prévoit pas le
financement de sa mise en oeuvre
ce pas demain devrait revenir devant
l'assemblée plénière en 2020
mais on retiendra que ce débat était le
premier où les conseillers de la
majorité ont montré ouvertement leur
désaccord avec le conseil exécutif